it is time for drew's news when i say
good you say news good no
good no
that's new
i've never done that before thank you
for trying it with us and i gotta say it
does feel really good and i'm also here
with the best news man in the biz rossi
ross matthew hi everybody
when you say good they say news
yeah all right well
speaking of news
well first things first we gotta go over
to britney spears instagram for a second
like i do every single morning i don't
know if you saw this true but did you
see britney posted that out of the
thousands of celebrities she's met in
her life there are only two that have
left her completely speechless kate
hudson
and drew barrymore
how about that
she said i love this she said that
instead of talking to you she she was so
flustered she just ran away from you and
she also wrote that sisterhood is
profound and that she admires you so
much drew did you read this like when it
just popped up on uh britney's insta um
everyone at the show because i was down
um here filming
came running up to me and was like did
you see did you see
and uh so i was like and then i i just
said you know i'll i'll see it when i
get upstairs i want to be like
thoughtful i want to read every word
that she says
um
[Music]
i uh i really want to respond
thoughtfully
i really want to choose my words the
right way um i'm i'm so excited i
i am
i really am
looking forward to her writing her book
because i just think it is such a smart
and intelligent way to tell her story
it'll get us all reading and off our
screen so thank you brittany for that
and she will control that narrative and
she will tell us in her own words and
it's just a brilliant
way for us to be invited in
to her world and so in a response i just
gotta choose my words carefully
i can't wait it is such a moment for me
i have so much
i have so many feelings towards her so
much profoundness so how do you
encapsulate that in a post she managed
to do it now i got to figure it out but
really when you put your words out there
um britney spears we're all listening so
i'm really excited for your book yeah
me too how cool
i can't wait for her book and i have to
say i've said it before i'll say it
again if she doesn't call her book
stronger than yesterday girl there's a
title am i right can you tell her
uh i just i i really i i
i i we have some unique journeys in
common and
i don't posture to know her or
understand her or
say i'm like her or that our journey is
aligned but there's just a
tremendous amount of um understanding
and empathy
that i have for her it's hard for me to
put into words the way i feel about her
but it is
beautiful it is yeah i would love to be
a fly on a wall for a conversation
between the two of you that would be
fascinating i would give anything to be
that fly too yeah
[Music]
you